[Music]
three amazing health benefits of lion's
main mushroom Lion's main mushroom is a
medicinal mushroom that has been used in
traditional Chinese medicine for
centuries number one it improves brain
health Lion's main mushroom contains
compounds like harrisonones and
adenosines which have been shown to
protect brain cells from damage and
degeneration it also boosts the
production of nerve growth factors in
the brain particularly in the
hippocampus which is very important for
our memory number two it can be a
natural cure for depression and anxiety
Arena scenes present in lion's mane have
been shown to have anti-anxiety and
antidepressant effects animal studies
published in the Journal of phyto
Medicine found that Adena signs help to
reduce anxiety levels in several Animals
number three lion's mane improves
immunity lion's mane contains a number
of polysaccharides such as beta glucans
these are known for stimulating
macrophage activity increasing CD4 cells
as well as boosting the activity of
natural killer cells it also improves
the response of tea helper cells to
pathogens remember to stay curious and
stay healthy